let's speak to a few more people today
via Discord we take calls at
davidpackman.com
Discord if you would like to chat just
raise your hand it's very simple we're
gonna go to Ricardo from Montreal Canada
of course in the province of Quebec
Ricardo welcome to the program what is
on your mind today as you get all of
your various technical issues that I can
tell you're having sorted out
Ricardo from Montreal welcome
hi can you hear me yes I can
oh hi perfect hi David this is my first
time ever calling on any show ever like
and every like uh calling or using
Discord so I'm actually kind of nervous
right now and uh and uh this is my first
time ever doing a call on Discord so
well let's make it a good one Ricardo
please
yes so hi David so I know that um I've
actually been following your show since
2020 I've been listening to every single
uh episode on on your show since 2020.
I'm actually a long time listener and um
I just want to ask you a question
because I know I know you've said time
and time and time and time again that
humans are really bad at um predicting
like future events yeah but How likely
uh like do you think it's gonna happen
that America is going to become a
right-wing dictatorship I have I have no
idea you know the thing about these
questions Ricardo is remember during the
State of the Union addresses when Trump
was president and he would say
America will never be a socialist
country do you remember that
I think so I think uh I don't know that
was probably like in 2020 or 2021 I
think
I think you know in any case and I would
say
Trump is right that America is not about
to be a socialist country there's no
risk of that there's no socialist in
position of power Etc so one of the
things Trump's doing is he's trying to
overstate the risk of a socialist
country but never never is a very long
time I think that's a very dumb
prediction to make 500 years a hundred a
thousand who knows you know so will
America be a right-wing dictatorship I
have absolutely no idea it depends on
the decisions that are made and me
giving you an answer definitive answer
would be nothing better than just a wild
guess could America become a right-wing
dictatorship absolutely is it closer now
than it was I don't know 15 years ago I
think the answer is yes but I I beyond
that I don't know
mm-hmm yeah that makes sense uh that's a
total um uh valid answer uh but I'm just
I'm just like asking this question
because it's really just from a
perspective of a concerned Canadian
because we're watching we're watching
here from up up here and uh we we
realize what's what's happening
um every single day and uh really just
concerns the heck out of this yeah I I
would be concerned too and listen you
can be a little less concerned than if
you're in the United States so at least
you have that
yeah that that's true that's true but uh
I just really wish uh all the best for
you guys and I just hope that uh you
guys are able to like sort out
everything that's going on there
um like I just really wish the best
because that that just really really
seems uh very concerning and hopeful I
appreciate it normal uh I don't know how
long it will take maybe like 10 years 20
years but we'll see because I know that
um 75 million people voted for Trump in
2020 right uh and um and there's still
like millions and millions of people
that still follow Donald Trump and her
are his still his art and supporters
that will defend him no matter what very
much so so but and and look at the I
think I guess with the 2022 midterms
that was kind of um a good sign because
it just showed a bit like the the waning
power of the Trump Maga movement
um but we'll see we'll see what happens
in like 2024 especially with all the
troubles that Trump is facing right now
I hope so I hope so Ricardo listen uh
Saint Viator or Fairmont Bagel which do
you prefer in Montreal
you think it's better
yeah I think so okay and have you ever
been to Tommy for brunch
oh boy uh my show has millions and
millions of restaurants so
um I don't I don't think I have I don't
know about millions of restaurants but I
recommend it check it out it's a good
spot all right get the eggs benedict
thank you I'm exaggerating I but I know
there's there's quite a few but I heard
that this interesting statistic that
apparently if you were to visit every
single restaurant uh I think three times
a day for the next 18 years you it would
it would take that amount of time to
visit every single restaurant in
Montreal I believe I believe it Ricardo
I will be back in Montreal soon and I
look forward to it
yeah all right well we'll be happy happy
to have you back all right Ricardo from
Montreal great to hear from you very
very much appreciate it